Well, good morning again beloved. It's good
to see you wide awake after getting woken up
by the storms this morning. I'm sure so glad you made it. We're taking
a bit of a break this week from our series
through Micah. It's the holiday weekend. And so
just kind of don't want anybody to miss out as we
walk through verse by verse in that book. And so we're gonna dive back
into the next Psalm up as we
take a decade's long journey through that book. We're now
three years into it. In fact, we are at one
third of the way through it today as we pick up Psalm 50. So
take your copy of God's word and turn there with me find half
way and then turn left you get to Psalm 50 big number
50 in the Book of Psalms.
But here's what's funny as we just pick up the next one. That's up in
these kind of off weeks like this and it's really interesting
that what we're going to see in we didn't
plan it this way. But what Psalm 50 is going to show us
is it's very much like Micah the whole thing feels like
it sounds like it. There's a lot of the same kinds of
themes like God's people had turned
away judgment was coming. And so we're gonna see God's response
to his people as they rebelled and
really what we're going to press into today is what
true worship looks like.
that's the whole theme of Psalm 50 and what God was addressing here is
what does true worship really look like
as we get into it today though this past Monday and Tuesday Emily and
I my wife got to attend a marriage retreat in
Oklahoma City and it's always good to get away kind of
a good time to just reconnect and spend focused time
together, but more importantly it does give us an opportunity to renew
our relationship now, we're in a great place.
We have always been in our marriage a great
place because we put the work into it, by the way. It doesn't just happen.
You have to like regularly scheduled maintenance on your
car. You kind of need to just do some checkups along the way.
But as we were there I was thinking about my wedding
ring and we just had it of course right there
on my finger and just thinking about certain things but but really
thinking about how this hundred dollars stainless steel
band how this is a reminder
of the Covenant that we entered into
over 17 years ago in our
marriage.
And how it daily reminds me as I wear it
right here. It just daily reminds me of the things that
we committed to each other under God together.
Well, that's essentially what God is going to do with Psalm 50.
It's kind of like a spiritual marriage retreat with his
bride.
Where there's this desire he has to renew the
relationship.
To refresh what's been missing something that as
he speaks about this true worship idea.
He calls his people. He calls us he calls
them.
to this renewed relationship
So we're going to see here in Psalm 50
and we see right away versus 1 through 6 where God lays
out this appeal to his people.
It says the mighty one God the Lord
he speaks and summons the Earth from the rising of
the sun to its setting out of Zion the
Perfection of beauty God shines forth.
Our God comes he does not keep silence before
him as a devouring fire around
him a mighty Tempest
He calls to the heavens above and to the Earth that he
may judge his people.
Gather to me my faithful ones who made
a covenant with me by sacrifice.
The heavens declare his righteousness for God
himself is Judge.
Will stop there for a moment.
This first picture of God the author
paints it it sure sounds a lot like Micah 1
remember we walk through the start of it and just the picture
of God coming down from the mountain. This Mighty
God. It says Yahweh that he's showing
himself to be visibly strong. He's the
one overall the Transcendent one. He is
God.
But he calls to the whole earth here and
notice as he does that he's he's inviting every person
to listen to his words. He's inviting people to to
hear him as he does that though notice.
It's not a blessing that he's bringing.
It says he's coming verse 6 as judge.
Calls the whole earth. He's coming as judge and
Psalm 19:1 reminds us the same idea that
the heavens declare his righteousness that
he's a worthy judge. He does all things
right? That's the word justice. He does everything according to
the rightness of it.
In fact, the Hebrew word for righteousness here is sedek.
Which is a word that means everything in its right
order.
So righteousness Justice in some ways as well
is is everything as it should be?
It's really what Deuteronomy 32 verse 4
describes about God. This is back in the pinnitude
the first five books of the Bible. This is what Deuteronomy 32:4
describes about God. It says the rock
not Dwayne Johnson The Rock talking about God his
work is perfect.
It's right for all his ways are Justice.
A god of faithfulness without iniquity just and
upright is he that's that's righteousness. That's
God in himself as just
and the judge
And so he calls the whole earth and says hey, it's it's all
coming in to hear me as I
speak Justice I speak rightness.
But notice he makes a distinction in verse 5.
He says gather to me my faithful ones
who made a covenant with me by sacrifice.
So he's not talking about all people in this moment. He's
talking about his people.
Those ones he has a special relationship with and he's calling them
out distinctly even as everybody gets to listen in
he calls them distinctly because something's out
of order in their relationship.
He wants to renew that relationship with his people.
In other words, they might have the name faithful.
But is it in name only?
Are they truly the faithful ones of God?
And so he's calling them back to renew that relationship. He's
calling his people to himself and
say hey, let's spend some time together. Let's talk.
And listen church. That's that's what he's doing for us every Sunday
in here.
As We Gather to worship him like this I pray that
it's not just as we'll see in a little bit not just what you do because
it's Sunday.
Not just a ritual we go through to make it
till lunch. He's summoning our hearts to
A Renewed relationship with him.
It's kind of like a wedding ring, right? It's a reminder of what that
Covenant means of marriage between me and my wife. This is
a reminder of what he's called us to and what
he's done for us.
And so what happens in here on Sundays, but remember that's also a
daily reminder.
Right. This this is a I don't just wear this on Sundays, right?
I wear this every day and God. Does that through
his word? Does that through his Spirit? He's a daily calling
us to be in renewed relationship
believer. Listen, you ought to feel God tugging on
your heart regularly.
Now you should feel him convicting you of
sin. So you repent and renew the relationship. You should
feel him drawing your heart to spend time
with him intimately regularly.
Quietly so, you know his heart and
you know that you're you're freely opening your heart to him.
He should be pulling your heart towards him in that.
If he's not if you don't feel that then you should
be concerned.
Let me just think about it was again me and my wife if
I never talk to her if I never spent time
with her never listen to her. We might still
be married doubtful. Right? We might still be
married, but there would be at least no relationship at all
between the two of us.
That's what God's doing. It's wanting us to renew the relationship
together. He's calling us back to him.
to renew that
Okay. So how do we do that?
He's called us. He says here's what we're going to talk about.
But how do we renew that? What's the heart issue that
God is wanting to address in his people here in Psalm
50.
Well, here's the first way we renew the relationship. It's through grateful worship.
through grateful worship
It's going to give us a couple more as we get into it. But grateful worship is the first
one look at verses 7 through 15. We'll
see this truth. It it starts with almost a satirical
reframing of the Shema and
Deuteronomy 6. He said hero people Israel. I am
your God. Here's what I want of you. He says something similar here,
but it's almost kind of a satire over that.
And notice as I read this there's a condition to what he's
talking about verses 7 through 15.
God says here o my people and I will
speak.
Oh Israel, I will testify against you. I am God your
God.
Now here it is. Not for your sacrifices. Do I rebuke you your
burnt offerings are continually before me I will
not accept a bull from your house or goats from your folds
for every beast on the forest is mind the
cattle on a thousand hills. I know all the birds of the hills
all that moves and the field is mine. God says
if I were hungry, I would not tell you for the world and it's fullness
our mind.
Do I eat the Flesh of bulls or drink the blood of
goats?
No, basically, he says instead offer to
God a sacrifice of Thanksgiving.
Perform your vows to the most high.
Call upon me in the day of trouble.
I will deliver you and you shall glorify me.
Now to get what he's saying here, you have to understand the sacrificial
system and the way that God set up
worship to be done at this
time. Right? There were laws that were happening all
throughout that the first five books about we go read those there were
laws for when and how people were
to bring animals to sacrifice at the temple
mainly because they needed forgiveness. And this was the
way God set it up to work and the only way he would forgive was
through the shedding of blood.
Because the penalty for sin is death and so
something had to die. Thankfully it could be a substitute.
Didn't have to be you every single time. It could be a substitute. But
what they had to do is they had to keep bringing those animals to
regularly cover their sins.
She got that side of the sacrifices. Then there were
feasts and festivals. It would bring more animals and more animals like
they were just a lot of blood. Can you imagine how much that was happening
all day every day?
That's what God said it up to be.
But notice in this passage that God's not referring in verse
8 to the actual practice of making those
sacrifices because he says you're doing it right you
actually get the logistics right is what he says.
You're doing the practice correctly?
But here's why he was not accepting their sacrifices.
Because they didn't care about their own spiritual condition.
In fact, they were trying to manipulate God through the
sacrifice. It's like we can do whatever we want as long
as we do these rules right long as we sacrifice right God's gonna
be okay with us.
Because apparently what this comes from is they had started
to believe The Narrative of other false religions
around them that sacrifices met
some kind of a need in that God.
and their God
my wife and I went to India in 2007 and
we saw it there.
That there were shrines everywhere.
hundreds upon hundreds in every
corner of the city
And what people would do is they would bring food to these
Idols to feed that God.
but the problem was
you walk around back and you see the caretaker of whatever Shrine that
is and he just taking baskets of that food and just dumping it
in the alley.
And monkeys and dogs and whatever else would come and eat
it and they believe that the God form would
take on a dog or a monkey form and and what
he did and that's what it needed was to be provided for.
but if it's a true God
does it need Provisions, right?
That's what he says here in verses 10 through 13. The true.
God doesn't need anything. He says every Beast.
On the forest is mine the cattle in a thousand hills.
I know all the birds of the hills all that moves in the field is mine.
It's like I already got everything I need I don't need anything from you.
If I were hungry, I wouldn't tell you because the world like if
I really didn't need to eat which is a a question that assumes no
to that answer right if I did need to eat.
I wouldn't tell you could already have all everything. I need the world is fullness or
mind. Do I eat the Flesh of bulls drink the blood of goats? Like I don't even
eat like you do. So, why are you trying to provide
for me?
It's the same thing. The Apostle Paul said in Athens in Acts
chapter 17. He says verse 24 The God
Who made the world and everything in it being Lord of Heaven
and Earth does not live in temples made by human hands nor
is he served by human hands as though he needed
anything.
Since he himself gives to all mankind life and breath
and everything. It's the same thing. We saw in
India, right? He's like you don't need to feed God. He doesn't need
anything. In fact gives you everything you have.
So what all this is saying?
What God is saying to his people is that you can't put me on a starvation
diet to get what you want.
Give or not just to get you in my stead here
in my debt. That's not how this works. He
doesn't need anything from us.
So what does he want from us?
What did he want from them?
verse 14 offer to God a sacrifice
of Thanksgiving
you might say that differently make Thanksgiving your sacrifice to
God.
Perform your vows to the most high call upon me in the
day of trouble. I will deliver you and you shall glorify me.
What he wants is grateful worship.
grateful worship
He doesn't want us to just go through the motions.
To just do the rituals to sing
or to give without having to Heart behind it.
It's not what he wants.
You can do all that you can do it. Right and he doesn't want it. He doesn't accept it
because this is what he wants. He wants a living relationship with
us not just dead formalism where we
go through all the things we supposed to do because that's the
way we grew up doing it. No, he wants a living relationship and
he's given us worship as an outlet for
that for us to express our gratitude to
him.
And notice here, it has nothing to do with
with style with contemporary or
traditional or whatever any sort of style because
we should be able to worship God no matter the style.
This is because this this worship has
nothing to do with that. It has everything to do with our hearts.
with gratitude
with Thanksgiving. He says as our sacrifice of
worship and praise to God.
Because Ephesians 5 19 and 20 says we are to sing
and make Melody to the Lord with your heart.
Giving thanks always and for everything to
God the Father the name of Lord Jesus Christ.
Like singing is just giving thanks for
everything to our God.
That's the essence of worship Church.
Which if we start thinking about that way?
That means it goes way beyond Sunday mornings, right?
I guess not just about what happens in here. It
includes this. Yes that this is not just a formalistic ritual
that we come together and we sing a few songs
because that's what we do on Sundays.
This is not just like an entertainment venue where
you merely watch and then judge if you liked it or
not. That's not what this is about. This is us singing
Praise out of thankfulness in our
hearts to God.
And because that's who he is and because that's
what he's done. Then really if our hearts are
right worship should explode in this room, right?
Like if we know that we have nothing else, but
him.
In the end nothing else then our Thanksgiving should just
pour out of our lives here.
I remember hearing the story of Believers in the underground Church
in China.
Where they travel hours just to meet
together once a month maybe once a quarter.
Just a few other believers that they know of and they they
meet in different locations. So they can't be tracked and and the
whole process of that they also as they meet together. They
can't even Sing Out Loud because if someone heard them singing out
loud, they would get turned in and arrested.
So what they do?
Is they just simply mouth the words
of the praise songs?
Maybe Whispering if anything.
But they're just looking around at each other and they're all in unison
and singing these songs together.
without any noise coming out
yet as they do that.
They are just weeping in gratitude for what
God has done for them.
They literally have nothing else yet.
They're so thankful in their worship.
Would you be willing to worship like that?
Would you be willing to Worship in
a situation where you're at fear for your life? You don't
know who's coming through that door. You got a special knock to make sure they get
in right like all of the would you be willing to Worship in a way that you're you're
never gonna be entertained by that you're never gonna
enjoy preferentially one way or the other you are just looking at
each other knowing Jesus is all we have.
Or would you jump ship real fast? Because this is just not enough for me.
It's how to check our hearts in this right. Here's another way to check your heart even even
as we gather together in this room like this regularly
is your heart unmoved as we sing and
as we preach the gospel.
Like are you completely disengaged over what we're
doing towards God. Are you more
focused on preference or Nostalgia than
we are at responding to Jesus and
what he's done for us?
See what we're trying to do here every week is we're trying to facilitate
true worship. We're not just going through the
motions. We're not just here to put on a show for other people.
And I know there might be elements. You don't prefer every week as We
Gather, but what you can address is your own heart.
That's what you can control and your heart. What
is my intent? Why am I here? What are we doing here? What am
I supposed to be doing here?
Because worship is not just to make you feel better.
Worship is not just to impress other people around
you that they think better about you. You must
remember I must remember it's so easy for me
to go through the motions.
I must remember that this is for the
Lord. I'm responding to him in
this.
again, though
Yes, it has implications for what we do in here but it also has
implications beyond Sunday mornings, right?
that really
when I say you are sent at the end of worship Gathering worship
never really ended.
We don't end worship. You see what I mean by that right
worship never really ends. I mean, just listen to
the way Romans 12:1 says this
I appeal to you therefore by the
mercies of God to present your bodies
as a Living Sacrifice.
Holy and acceptable to God, which is your
spiritual worship.
whole self
Is God's desired sacrifice now?
not animals
not just actions
Your whole self and what motivates that he
says, I appeal to you by the mercies of God.
It's the mercy of God that you
deserve God's judgment and he gave you Mercy instead that
God put the Judgment you deserve on Jesus instead.
That he's a sufficient substitute his blood on that
altar covers it all you don't have to keep giving it. You don't have
to keep bringing animals. You've got all of it covered. That's what
motivates worship.
Because again worship is not just singing. That's what motivates Worship in
every corner as a Living Sacrifice.
A spiritual worship to God is through this.
And so just like I said our praise in here should
explode because of the mercy of God,
we should live differently because of the mercy of
God as well.
I just again I keep going back that the image
you should think today is marriage wedding ring relationship. Just
like I want to sing the Praises of my wife.
And live differently.
For her is because she's loved me so well.
And I look at that and I think how else should I
respond to that? Should I take advantage of that should take take it for
granted? No, I should change everything because I
want to honor her.
How much more true Is that real true in our relationship
with God?
She's an imperfect example of
of love. Yes.
God is not. He has loved us perfectly. That's
why it says we should want to glorify him
right the end of verse 15. I'll deliver you you
shall glorify me. That's what we should want to do
as we sing in here as we live out there.
And the more you do it out there the easier it is to do it in here.
that fuels this
so worship is what God wants from us.
grateful worship
but along those lines see he's calling this
renewal of a relationship in Psalm 50, but he raises
another issue along those lines this time directed
at those who claimed his name but lived
in opposition lived otherwise
continue on look at verse 16 down through 22
But to the wicked God says now
this is not Wicked people out there. This is
wicked people of his who are supposed to be the faithful ones, right?
But to the wicked God says what right have you
to recite my statutes or take my Covenant
on your lips?
For you hate discipline and you cast my words behind you.
If you see a thief you're pleased with him, you keep company
with adulterers. You give your mouth free
reign for evil your tongue frames deceit you sit
and speak against your brother.
You slander your own Mother's Son.
These things you have done and I've been silent.
You thought that I was one like yourself, but now I
rebuke you and lay the charge before you.
Mark this then you who forget God.
Lest I tear you apart and they're be none to deliver.
Again, this sounds a lot like Micah, right?
That these supposed Covenant people of
God. We're taking the grace and mercy of God and stomping on
it as if it were trash.
That's why God calls them to renew the
relationship here through sincere obedience.
Grateful worship was part of it that they
should respond and do things the right-heartedly in right-hearted
ways. But then now since you're obedience is
another way to renew that relationship.
Because he says it here.
That these people these Wicked ones had God's Commandments
on their walls had God's commandment
in their history, but had none of God's Commandments in
their hearts.
It's verse 17 you cast my words behind you.
It would be like if I took this wedding ring and just tossed
it.
Forget it.
It's what they're doing here.
Because remember in the Covenant agreement God made with them
at Mount Sinai The Ten Commandments Moses comes
off the mountain and says here's the ten rules to live
by here's here's God's covenant with us. This is
what he asked of us things. Like do not steal do not
commit adultery. Do not lie. The basic ones, right?
What were these people doing?
They were encouraging stealing.
They were hanging out with adulterers and just saying no big deal.
They were speaking evil speaking lies speaking slander
against their own family.
Just the exact opposite of what God
Said to do.
And that's bad enough, of course, but just like we saw with Micah these
people didn't think God was going to do anything about it.
He's gracious, right? He's kind. He's patient. That's
who God is that's his character. That's God. He's good.
gross miscalculation, right
look at verses 21 and 22 again. God says to
them these things you have done and I have been silent.
You thought that I which you can even phrase
that in the original language you thought that the I am
right Yahweh. You thought that I was one
like yourself you thought that the I am
Yahweh would just like you.
But now I rebuke you lay the charge before you mark this
you who forget God lest. I tear you apart. They're being
none to deliver.
In other words God is saying here I made this
Covenant with you. I am God.
There's a faithful response to that Covenant, but
what you're doing is not it.
What you are doing so-called faithful ones is not
being faithful and so judgment was
coming.
Remember Church Romans 2:4 says that we must not presume
upon the riches of his
kindness and forbearance and patience.
what that means is that
when God gives us.
Grace it should lead us to repentance.
To not take advantage of his Mercy.
So since for them and for us God has
not brought full judgment yet.
What should our response be to him?
Well, it's just like back in Micah we saw.
Turn back to him.
insincere obedience
if you're running astray One Direction wrongly
he says turn around and go the other way.
Sincere obedience. It's a whole idea behind the word. Holy.
We sing it we talk about it the word holy means that
God has set apart his people to be
distinct to be different than the world around
us to show him off that we are his people.
Which by the way is how Romans 12 continues?
verse 2 after this call to be
a Living Sacrifice verse 2
says then do not be conformed to
this world.
To fall into the mold of the world around us
don't be conformed but be transformed by the
renewal of your mind.
That by testing you may discern what is the will of God what is good and acceptable
and perfect?
What that means is that sincere obedience
we're talking about here that God is calling us to is a desire
to follow God's will to follow God's plan
with every part of my life every
action every thought every inner response
every outer response. It's all saying
God. I want your will not mine. I want your plan not
mine. You're in charge, not me.
Sincere obedience is a desire to follow his will.
That's what for Samuel 15:22 says.
God says has the Lord as great Delight in
burnt offerings and sacrifices as in obeying
the voice of the Lord.
Behold to obey is better than sacrifice.
Meaning you could bring all of these animals you want.
Obedience is more faithful to God.
That's what he wants more than all
of the rituals that we go through.
But again, let me be clear about something.
Notice the point here.
Was Not Mere obedience
Because what can happen is that can get weird where we
start to try to earn our Salvation. We do it just because
we have to or whatever and you just say obedience. That's it.
No, remember God's calling us to sincere obedience.
Because like we saw with worship true worship
comes from the heart. It comes from inside of
you out to the rest of people and world
and all the outs external actions, right?
It comes from inside first same with this obedience comes should
come from the heart. It should come up from inside
of you because you want to because you're
grateful for what God has done for you. That's what
obedience come that's sincere obedience.
And so just like with worship.
It's not enough to fill the air with raised hands
and and swelling choruses if we're not
concerned with truth and equity and justice.
for not concerned about giving effort towards
applying his word.
To obeying God like if we're not doing that out
there, he's looking at this like this will aim is five says God
says this take away from me the noise of
your songs.
To The Melody of your Harps. I will not listen.
But let Justice roll down like Waters and
righteousness.
like an Ever flowing stream
Saying you can come in here and raise your hands and sing We have
greatest music in the whole history of the church. We can do all of that.
He said but if you're not trying to live out the faith
out there. I'm not even listening.
Obedience is just as much worship.
It's from the heart sincere obedience
is worship too because just like
singing should be a grateful response to his grace. Your obedience
should be a grateful response to his grace, too.
I just think about it.
How else should I respond to the one who
lived the perfect life I couldn't live.
Who died the death I deserved.
Who defeated the enemy of sin and death? I could never defeat on
my own how else should I respond to that?
But that church is where it starts that is where it
starts.
Because Psalm 50 ends this marriage retreat.
By saying you renew the
relationship first and foremost through
humble faith.
through humble faith
It's in verse 23. It's what grounds the rest of it.
This is how he ends he's just talked judgment. He just said
all the things verse 23. He says the one who offers Thanksgiving
as his sacrifice glorifies me.
To one who orders his way. Rightly. I
will show the salvation of God.
Again, this is not saying you can earn your salvation in any way.
That's still a gift. Yes, but remember the context.
They were bringing sacrifices for the
wrong reason.
They were trying to manipulate God. They
were bringing it as ritual. There was nothing in their heart that
was driving it. It was not sincere in
any way. That's why God says the one who glorifies him is the
one who offers Thanksgiving as a sacrifice.
That's true worship. The one who comes with a
grateful heart for all that. God has done. That's the
faith side of this equation.
Right you are saying.
And you know in your heart at the deepest part of
Who You Are.
That you are joyful over what God has
done in your place.
That you trust his work in your place. That's
faith
Right, that's trust in him in your place that
is core to all of this working as
it should but then he says this other phrase. He says
the one who orders his way rightly.
It's the same word as righteousness back
in verse 6 that God is righteousness. Now,
we order our way rightly.
And so we now align our
lives with God's right way.
That's what he means by this with God's path
with God's direction. We align our lives with
it. So we got the faith. Peace. This here
is the humble.
piece
because to align your life with God's plan you have to acknowledge that
his plan is better than yours.
His plan is right and yours is often wrong.
That you are acknowledging. He's
in charge what he says goes I submit
to him and his way is not try to make him submit to my ways.
It's humble faith.
But again, that's true worship, right?
Where you are, so grateful for his salvation that you
die to yourself.
That you you allow him to direct your life.
That you prioritize what he says to prioritize that
is true worship.
And you do what Hebrews 13?
Verses 15 and 16 says that in light of what Jesus has
done then through him. Let us continually offer
up a sacrifice of praise to
God.
That is the fruit of lips that acknowledge his name.
Not just that we talk about him.
But we acknowledge his name same with Proverbs 3
you give him the credit for what he is doing
in your life you follow him as your lead that's
acknowledging his name and then verse 16 says practically
do not neglect to do good and to share what
you have for such sacrifices are
pleasing to God.
This is true worship.
So, how is God?
Calling you back to him today.
How does he want to renew that relationship with you?
How does he want to get you to feel the Blessed
weight of that daily reminder?
The wedding ring reminding of the Covenant. How
does he want to remind you of that feeling in your heart
of the renewal of the relationship the weight of
the Covenant The Joy it is to be in relationship.
How does he want to renew that today?
How does he want you to respond in grateful obedience?
and grateful worship
How does he want you to respond in that?
Remember it starts with humble Faith Church.
It starts with the fact that he is God your God
it says.
He is God your God. So listen.
fear Him
acknowledge his name give sacrifices of
Praise love him deeply for
all that he's done for you for all that. He's done
for us for who he is just worship him
let that drive everything about your life.